[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoje é o aniversário de uma senhora
muito especial muito especial e
importante na vida de todos nós
na minha particularmente ela é ela foi e
eu tenho certeza que ela continuará
sendo fundamental
ela me inspira todos os dias na minha
vida pessoal e mais do que qualquer
teste ou aplicação de teste vocacional
ela acertou em cheio na minha carreira
hoje ela faz 70 anos hoje ela faz 70
anos de história
setenta anos de sabedoria 70 anos
ensinamentos 70 anos de conquistas e
desde que ela nasceu ela tenta nos
ensinar de forma muito insistente uma
ideia muito muito muito simples mas
extremamente poderosa
essa é a idéia de que todos nós seres
humanos
dispomos dos mesmos direitos e das
mesmas liberdades
independente de quem somos
na verdade esse é o seu primeiro
ensinamento imagina revolução que essa
senhora não trouxe quando ela anunciou
isso no mundo em que algumas categorias
de pessoas
a realeza os europeus os brancos os
homens tiveram acostumados a desfrutar
de mais direitos do que os outros todos
seres humanos nascem livres e iguais em
direitos e dignidade que ela quis dizer
com isso
todos todos todos não importa quem somos
não importa se somos ricos e pobres
brancos pretos
não importa se somos pessoas boas se
somam as pessoas ruins
não importa se pagamos nossos impostos
se não pagamos nossos impostos
não importa se somos do gênero feminino
gênero masculino ou até fim desse a
gente imediatamente não se identifica
com nenhum desses dessas categorias
porque nascemos iguais e temos em nós
mesmos um valor fundamental é que
merecemos dos mesmos direitos e que
valor é esse dignidade à dignidade é
quase não é quase é como a que a gente
respira
a gente não pode vender a gente não pode
doar
a gente não pode comprar a gente não
pode perder
na verdade tem gente que pede mas não
deveriam e apesar dos 70 anos todos
esses ensinamentos iniciais que ela nos
deu
são tão relevantes hoje no brasil da
desigualdade e um país tão socialmente
sedimentado como nós
ela ensina no seu terceiro no seu
terceiro ensinamento ela fala que todos
temos direito à vida à liberdade e à
segurança pessoal de novo isso não é
para as pessoas que estão no nosso
convívio social
também não é para as pessoas só para as
pessoas que nasceram na suíça ou nas
pessoas que nasceram nos estados unidos
isso também vale para as pessoas que
nasceram nos bairros ricos do sudeste
brasileiro assim como vale também para o
sertanejo nordestino pro ribeirinhos da
amazônia
membro da comunidade uma favela em porto
alegre ou no rio
isso vale pra todos e isso é o que
significa uma característica essencial
daquilo que ela traz que a
universalidade a universalidade dos
direitos significativos fica em qualquer
país
a universalidade significa que ele
aplica a uma democracia a uma ditadura a
um país de governo de esquerda um país
que o governo de direita quando ela diz
por exemplo que ninguém será submetido à
prisão arbitrária ea tortura aos maus
tratos
ela também não fez nenhuma exceção ela
não disse que poderia torturar
militantes de esquerda durante a
ditadura militar do brasil
ela também não disse que hoje podem ser
torturados estudantes críticos ao
governo de nicolás maduro na venezuela
ela também não disse que pode torturar
moradores da periferia pretos pobres que
muitos de nós entendemos que a polícia
pode perfeitamente matar prender
torturar com absoluta impunidade
a tortura é submeter uma pessoa a
crueldades intensas em suportar as dores
físicas e psicológicas porque ela afeta
imediatamente um dos valores mais
absolutos como eu disse que a dignidade
é uma das piores violações de direitos
que pode acontecer e é por isso que nem
torturadores do passado nem todas as
dúvidas do presente
deveriam nunca serem celebrados como
heróis
o mesmo direito vale para todos nós no
sentido de que ninguém poderá ser
submetido à escravidão
ninguém poderá ter sua casa invadida no
meio da madrugada e desaparecer
ninguém pode ser acusado de um crime sem
ter a presunção da inocência
e também ninguém
e todos nós temos direito a um
julgamento justo que significa o direito
da ampla defesa e de ser assessorado por
um advogado por exemplo
todos nós temos direito à opinião e à
liberdade de expressão
isso significa que do mesmo jeito que
estou falando com vocês todos vocês
também podem falar livremente da sua
opinião expor suas idéias sem temer
represálias ou sem temer ser punidos por
uma opinião que emitissem pensar que
você pode sair daqui atravessar a rua
ser preso e torturado por uma opinião
que você tem
ninguém pode ser submetido a essas
condições
olha como ela é esperta tava falando
dela voltando a falar dela porque ela
que trouxe todos esses ensinamentos e
desde 1948 ela já falava que todos têm
direito à remuneração igual por trabalho
igual
é interessante que aqui no brasil hoje
ainda hoje nós mulheres mesmo que
desempenhamos o mesmo papel mesmo papel
profissional do que um homem ainda
ganhamos menos mas não dá para dizer que
nós enquanto país nós enquanto nação não
aprendemos nada com ela
nós por exemplo incorporamos todos os
seus ensinamentos dentro da nossa da mãe
de todas as nossas legislações que
constam constituição federal
nós também avançamos progredimos na
realização de muitos dos ensinamentos do
de direitos que ela colocou nós
conquistamos por exemplo proteções
especiais para populações que tiveram
seus direitos histórica e
sistematicamente violados negros
mulheres população lgbt e pessoas com
deficiência indígenas mas é muito
importante deixar claro que o que todo
mundo pensa que é
isso são privilégios são direitos a mais
não porque foram sistematicamente
historicamente discriminados
esses grupos merecem proteções especiais
simplesmente para que possam exercer os
direitos da mesma forma que os outros
infelizmente no entanto com 70 anos de
existência
talvez hoje ela essa senhora viva sob o
intenso ataque sobre um momento de
bastante ameaça
nesse ano que a gente está vivendo se
você olha por exemplo o direito a buscar
proteção asilo em outro país
quando você se sente perseguido vemos
que temos ainda muito a caminhar quando
a gente vê autoridades e políticos do
mundo inteiro propondo erguer muros
fechar fronteiras ea gente nem precisa
ir muito longe no brasil recentemente
quantas vezes a gente já ouviu propostas
de devolver os venezuelanos e
venezuelanas que estão vivendo num país
em absoluto colapso mas quem é ela quem
é essa senhora que hoje faz aniversário
e cujos ensinamentos
nós temos tentado aprender a declaração
universal dos direitos humanos que hoje
faz 70 anos cujos princípios e valores
que inspiraram convenções acordos ao
redor do mundo inteiro inclusive no
brasil por isso que a gente tem
obrigação de realizá los
a declaração universal dos direitos
humanos é diferente de qualquer outro
acordo anterior porque ela vale pra
todos
para os quase 8 bilhões de habitantes da
terra é diferente dos outros porque ela
coloca nós a pessoa humana no centro de
todas as relações
eleonor roosevelt foi a primeira dama
dos estados unidos talvez no período do
períodos mais sombrios da humanidade
mais tristes que foi a segunda guerra
mundial
dez anos depois da declaração
ela falou numa palestra mas onde começam
os valores dos direitos humanos
fundamentais universais em pequenos
lugares perto da sua casa
tão perto e tão pequenos que não é
possível nem visualizá los no mapa não
tinha google maps naquela época hoje
talvez a gente consiga visualizar no
mapa todos esses lugares
mas o ponto fundamental que ela quis é
mostrar pra gente é justamente esse que
o ser humano está no centro que nós
somos merecedores dos direitos humanos e
por isso que a gente não pode desistir
aliená-los outros ou não respeitá los
o compromisso fundamental da carta
universal dos direitos humanos é que
qualquer violação ao redor do mundo nos
afeta como humanos seja não me amar onde
uma população rodrigo está sendo
perseguida seja na síria que ainda vive
uma guerra sangrenta
seja na embaixada da arábia saudita na
turquia onde o jornalista foi preso
morto e esquartejado todas as violações
de direitos humanos atingir como pessoa
nos atinge como seres humanos porque
corrói os princípios que nos protegem da
tirania e do autoritarismo e é por isso
que a gente precisa valorizar e defender
a declaração universal dos direitos
humanos
mas vocês podem perguntar mas como eu no
dia a dia como eu posso valorizar e
defender a declaração é muito simples é
se colocar no lugar do outro é fazer um
exercício nas situações mais
questionáveis de empatia de amor é
imaginar como você se sentiria ou alguém
da sua família seu filho seu amigo no
lugar de uma pessoa que tem seus
direitos
lados ninguém quer isso por isso que
hoje é um dia tão especial
parabéns declaração universal dos
direitos humanos
parabéns prometo que assim como milhares
de outros defensores dos direitos
humanos
eu lutarei por você e pelos valores que
você me ensinou
convido a todos para um grande parabéns
123 parabéns e obrigada
[Aplausos]